swaggy like her daddy north west takes
paris oak couture fashion week with mom
kim kardashian and she rocks her dad
kanye west's hand-me-down jacket
yes we love a family who upcycles
fashion looks she definitely has kanye's
outgoing personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or
who it might offend
check out the nine-year-old out and
about with her mama in the city of light
on tuesday where they both sport vibrant
colors northie dons a royal blue
letterman jacket from kanye's former
pastel brand which is also the same
jacket he wore in 2008 at the american
music awards
it's extremely important to me the
little fashionista paired the statement
piece with royal blue shades silver and
black platform boots and a black purse
meanwhile kim went for neon green
panther shoes a coordinating camouflage
print shirt and a silver purse
how many times in a row four but who's
counting
prior to touching down in france kim
teased their trip on her instagram story
sharing snaps of her and her cousin cc
bussie playing cards during the flight
and showing off a snapshot of grey
skittles that are available on her plane
khmer
talk about a boss move the mama 4 also
shared this sweet photo of north smiling
in the car clearly ready for her fashion
moment it's always so much fun
speaking of moments it's been an
eventful time for north who recently
celebrated her ninth birthday with a
unique wilderness themed party how did
you celebrate uh norse um
so she's really into special effects
makeup she does
like really good like wounds and scars
and really
she's really good at it so she was
taking classes i got her a teacher to
show her and get all of the supplies so
she wanted to teach her girlfriends and
we took about eight kids eight girls and
we went camping in the wilderness and
she wanted it to be really spooky and
she wanted
like these
mannequin heads and she taught everyone
there was a whole class that she taught
her friends how to do
special effects wounds and
scars and
i'm happy with that
north's talent with makeup is something
we've seen firsthand on her joint tick
tock account with kim now while we'll
just have to wait and see if she will
follow in her mom's footsteps by diving
into the beauty industry one thing we
know for sure is that she's embracing
her own creativity which is something
kim revealed to et she's always hoped
for i hope that they
just find their own motivation and no
matter what that is no matter what they
want to do in life i hope that they work
really hard i think they have good exam
i i learned from seeing both of my
parents work really hard and i think our
kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path
[Music]
you